let's turn now to Champaign and the
party's vice president Michelle O'Neill
who would have become the first Minister
after the party topped the last
elections earlier this year thank you so
much for being on the program for us
today we just heard from Sir Jeffrey
saying that Northern Ireland doesn't
need an election what it needs is better
negotiations and sorting out the brexit
protocol do you think that there needs
to be an election
good morning Sophie well firstly we did
have an election we had an election back
in May last year and I think that's
certainly my party you know the parties
were given a very strong mandate in
which to form a government actually to
support people trying to what is most
one of the most challenging times I
think that most people have been through
in terms of the cost of living crisis
but the outcome of that election is
continually being denied by the dup
um by Jeffrey Donaldson they're failed
to accept the outcome of that election
their field to form a government and
they've failed to work with the rest of
us to get people through these things so
you know we shouldn't have to have an
election
um because we have had one but
unfortunately that election result has
been disrespected now what we have at
this current moment in time is six
months post that election we have astero
Limbo with no government in place with
no ministers on post we've nobody taken
decisions in the interests of the paper
and it's just not acceptable it's just
not good enough
what's the difference between you know
the dep collapsing storm once over
something as fundamental as what they
see as the Constitutional question and
Chin Fame pulling it down for three
years over a botched green energy scheme
well it was a financial Scandal actually
that the eup designed and delivered um
it was a scandal that would have saw the
public part for 500 million pounds I
don't think any government anywhere in
the world would have withstood such a
scandal but I also think that at that
time whenever it did collapse we worked
every day to try to put it back together
again but the dep ran over to London to
prop up the Tories and their forward
interested in actually establishing the
government at home so I think that's
regrettable and not in that sense but
you know
I think where we are today is that the
public rightly deserve you know sensible
mature particular leaders working
together to try to form a government to
actually start to put money into their
pockets to get them through the course
live in crisis and unfortunately that is
not the case and we're caught up in the
midst of all of this mass chaos
dysfunction heartlessness if you like
observatories in London and the day you
pay you're on towards those people
instead of actually run towards the
people at home who actually want
politics to work you know I just think
that as we enter into next year which
will Mark 25 years of our peace process
25 years of our remarkable remarkable
Journey um or transformation in our
society and I think it's just such a
shame that we're sitting on a scenario
today in political Limbo with the public
are being denied access to democracy and
their votes but the do you appear Talent
paper right now their holds don't count
the election that they voted for and
they voted in in May of this year is
being disrespected and I just don't
think that's good enough
you said that the the DP in your view
I'm sure that they would disagree are
not interested in forming a government
you know if you believe that do you
think it's partly because they are
uncomfortable with effectively power
sharing with you know Sinn Fein first
minister
yes I don't think it's lost on The Wider
public I'd throw at the dep don't like
the male action results I don't think
it's lost in the way to Republic that
they have difficulty in forming a
government to be a deputy first minister
to my mandate which is to be the first
Minister uh given the recent election
results so I think it's not lost on
people that's actually the real
motivation here but the dep hide behind
the issues of the protocol they hide
behind all of that so what I want to say
in the time ahead is very mature
sensible political discussion between
both the British government and the EU
side let's find and agreed where to
solve the issues around the protocol and
I would make this kiss again disagree
with Jeffrey Donaldson the dup the
protocol isn't as a necessity and it's
here to stay there are things that can
be smoothed out there are things that
can be made to work better and I'm up
for that and I hope that's what we
achieve in the common weeks and months
there has been a renewed Focus if you
like between both the British government
and the EU side to get uh to have
discussions in terms of making the
protocol work and I urge that to
continue in Earnest and actually to be
ramped up and actually finding a great
way forward because the certain
instability that will bring will do two
things it will provide that certainly
instability would allow us to be able to
look towards investment opportunities
per second to that then it'll remove any
pretense from the EP in terms of forming
an executive with myself and with the
rest of the parties
um the collapse institutions are you
know about the protocol but I think as
you probably acknowledge also about you
know a lack of trust across the Divide
in a recent interview you said this and
I don't think any Irish person ever woke
up one morning and thought that conflict
was a good idea but the war came to
Ireland I think at the time there was no
alternative but now thankfully we have
an alternative to conflict and that is a
good Friday agreement
and if by saying that there was no
alternative to the violence that we've
seen from the IRA during the troubles
are you not worried that you're adding
to some of that distrust you know how
will that persuade unionists that you
can be a first Minister for all
well the public had gave me a mandate to
be first Minister for all that I said
that I wanted to be but I think that you
have to realize that we have been a
society that has been absolutely
transformed over the course of the last
25 years in our precious peace process
has to be held on to with everything
we've got unfortunately this Tory
government to care less for a peace
process and I think brexit um as a good
case in point you know brexit in the
Good Friday doing what we're never going
to be comparable but I think that you
know there's no doubt that we've had a
very um difficult past there's no doubt
that people have been hurt across the
across the pace across all over
community and all of my adult life has
been about building the peace but if
we're going to truly reconcile our
people if we're going to truly look
towards the future and if we're going to
unburden today's young people of the
past then we need to properly deal with
the past not as they acknowledge that
there are different narratives of the
past people have very different lived
experiences and we have to most
importantly ensure that those conditions
never ever exist again so for me this is
about looking towards the future as
opposed to looking towards the past but
we have to absolutely certainly deal
with the past and the approach of the
story government to for example bring
forward this bill in terms of dealing
with the past is absolutely shameful and
shambolic and it is not an there's no
clinical support for the legislation
that they're bringing through
Westminster in terms of an amnesty
there's no clinical support from any
political quarter from any of the
victims and Survivor scripts so how are
we going to look towards the future if
we don't properly analogly deal with the
past
um you're talking about the uh Tory a
government so I am interested to finally
just get your view on Rishi sunak the
new prime minister also of course we've
seen Chris Heaton Harris reappointed as
a Northern Ireland secretary do you
welcome those two appointments or do you
have any concerns
I'm so fairly look forward to today
whenever there isn't any interference in
terms of the British government in terms
of the Irish people as Affairs here and
however this is the scenario that we
find ourselves in today but there's no
doubt that these the Tory party don't
care less for the Good Friday agreement
they certainly don't care for the people
they're not acting in the interests of
anybody the past three months has been
about self-serve an agenda about Stanton
Park
um and I think that the policy decisions
of the Tories
um really make people's lives much much
more difficult every day and the events
of recent weeks and months have
demonstrated that
um but for now the the British
government are a coal guarantor of our
peace agreement and my interest is is
the interest of the people here so I
will work with them I encourage
um the new British prime minister to
continue to work with the EU to ramp up
those discussions find ways to smooth
out the protocol make it work and get a
better down and bring that certain
instability that the people here deserve
okay thank you very much uh Indy
Michelle O'Neal there